getting along is certainly no problem
for the property brothers that's just
one of the things that nischelle Turner
found out and she was the only one they
invited inside their new home renovation
show in Las Vegas right now where do you
get the idea for this one and how is
this different from the other we get
half a million messages that we teach on
social media from our fans and it's
people telling us like I have a home
we've been in it 30 years so many
memories but it's just not perfect and
that's why we're like you know what
we're gonna come in we're gonna make it
perfect
the twins eight HD TV show property
brothers forever home doesn't have any
buying or selling it's all about taking
ordinary homes and turning them into a
dream homes you have to learn and so I
get them in on demo day and we have them
tearing our cabinets we have them doing
everything poke hole actually the dog in
this house is the one that found this
giant that's the way I was wondering
what the heck dude so we're turning this
into join me this is gonna be a cool
little kid sport right now like fries
with that and while it may seem like
funny games with these two they knock
out 44 renovations a year last year the
company banked two reported half a
billion dollars so what's their secret
to avoiding sibling drama if there's
something bugging us we get it out
what's the longest you have stayed mad
at each other
[Music]
[Applause]